a new poll ahead of tonight's third
democratic debate shows frontrunner Joe
Biden and Elizabeth Warren neck-and-neck
in the Economist YouGov poll out
yesterday 24% of Democratic voters named
Biden or Warren as their first choice
they will share a debate stage for the
first time tonight along with eight
other candidates ed O'Keefe is in
Houston where the debate will be held
and what should we expect from this
matchup tonight we should expect Anthony
a lot of focus early on at least on
those two frontrunners the former Vice
President Joe Biden and senator
Elizabeth Warren the fact that they
haven't appeared on stage in those first
two rounds of debates signals that that
really will be the main focus tonight
and look if those summer debates were
kind of the warm-ups this is the point
at which really things start to matter
much more more Americans paying
attention the fact that there are only
ten of them involved but one other
subplot to keep an eye on tonight
California Senator Kamala Harris was
usually ranking about fourth right now
in surveys we found an interesting thing
in the CBS News battleground tracker
poll over the weekend it goes back and
talks to the same people that talked to
over the summer and found that 29
percent of people who had been
supporting Kamala Harris have switched
their allegiance to senator Elizabeth
Warren does Harris do something tonight
for her first time on stage with Warren
as well to clawback that support or does
Warren perhaps you even try to bring
more of it into her camp it'll be an
interesting dynamic to watch for that's
an interesting turn of events
Edie but what are you hearing about how
the candidates are preparing for tonight
Oh Gail they prepare in all sorts of
ways talk to some by Dan folks yesterday
who say he's been rehearsing some lines
potential answers to questions about
things like perhaps his previous support
for the war in Iraq I called one other
senior a to another member of the debate
stage last night who said no we're still
prepping him can't get to you right now
perhaps the most interesting thing we
saw yesterday
Andrew yang of course the entrepreneur
who is maintaining a pretty healthy
level of support in this spent most of
the afternoon on a basketball court
warming up with aides everyone does it a
little differently and
certainly one way to do it he did some
crowd surfing earlier in the week to
help very impressive a sure it all gets
caught on videos yes yes it's all part
of the marketing campaign thank you very
much we appreciate it